اربطوا أحزمة الأمان ،
لقد تعرضت هذه الحقيبة لبعض الاضطرابات ، وأعتقد
أن
المستهلك العادي سيذهب إلى ما
تبيعه حقيبة الطائرة الطويلة من طراز لويس مقابل 39000 دولار ،
يمكنك شراء طائرة فعلية مقابل شخص أقل
شهرة ينشر سيارة سيسنا مستعملة بسعر يزيد قليلاً عن 32000
دولار  لإثبات ذلك ، عرض منزل التصميم الفاخر
مجموعة ذات طابع السفر في
أحدث عرض للرجال ،
وكان هناك أكثر من عنصر لهواة الجمع
أو كما قال المصمم الشهير فيليب بلوك
وأعتقد أنه كان الخيال الذي
نريده جميعًا ، وكلنا نريد الهروب  غرف المعيشة في
الوقت الحالي ،
حسنًا مقابل 39000 ، هل يمكن أن تطير ،
هل يمكنك حتى العثور على الأشياء التي تضعها
هناك ، حيث يوجد chapstick الخاص بي
، هل قمت بفحص قمرة القيادة على
الجانب المشرق ،
وإلقاء نظرة على جميع الأميال التي يمكنك الحصول عليها عند
شراء هذا
المغطى بـ Louis riton الشهير  الشعار
يبدو وكأنه طائرة نقل عسكرية
ولكن من سينقلها ولكنك
سترى بالتأكيد تلك الحقيبة في مقاطع فيديو مغني الراب ،
إنها كاردي جدًا ربما ستعيش ليدي غاغا
لهذه الحقيبة إنها  هو عمل لويس
يتراجع عن المدير الفني للرجال
فيرجيل أبلوه الذي قام بالتغريد مرة واحدة ثم
حذف
التصميم لاحقًا هو أحدث عملية احتيال أقتبسها لي
عن ذلك ، وكان أحد الأشخاص الذين لا يحبون الموضة قد خرقوا
الحقيبة التي
عرض عليها شخص ما أن يلصق بعض
المقابض على هذا ،
وقد تم إغراء بعض المتابعين للأزياء
تبدو رائعة جدًا ولكن هذا الامتداد الجناح
سيكون لديك الكثير من
تحطم الطائرة مع تلك الحقيبة التي ستصطدم
بكل شيء
هذه حقيبة
تدعوك عمليًا لاستلامها
تعال طار معي ، دعنا
نطير بعيدًا فقط لا  لا أتوقع أن يتناسب
مع صندوق الأمتعة العلوي ،
أعتقد أن هذا شيء يجب
أن يجلس في حضنك مثل كلب الخدمة
الذي يتناسب تمامًا مع قناع النوم المنك الذي
تبلغ تكلفته 1100 دولار
[موسيقى]
المارد cnn نيويورك